- There is a special
technique that consultants use
to draft their slide presentations.
This is a technique that I've never seen
anybody use outside of consulting.
In this video I'm going to spill the tea
on a technique that I
used almost every day
when I was a project lead at McKinsey.
And when I needed to
draft the presentations
that then I wanted the
whole team to work on.
Welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich,
and here on my channel,
I want to help you become successful
in the first years of your career.
On this channel, I'm sharing
my tips and strategies
that I learned at McKinsey
and now working in a C-level
role at a German retailer.
But now let's jump right into it.
How do consultants draft their presentations
and to give you a sneak peek
what the end product will be,
I will show you a slide presentation
that I recently drafted,
where I use this technique.
So this is how it looks like guys,
so I'm holding this now in the camera,
I hope that you are able to see this.
This is something that is
called a Mickey Mouse Master,
also strawman, it is a
draft of a presentation,
that typically the project lead
or the partner in a
consulting context creates.
I remember in one of the very first weeks
I was working at McKinsey,
the project lead of that study
asked me to sit with him,
he would just take a piece of paper
and he would create a
master just like that
of the presentation.
Then he gave it to me and then this was
one of my very first tasks at McKinsey,
just to create a whole slide presentation,
just following exactly this technique.
So how exactly does it work?
How do you create such
a Mickey Mouse Master
or such a strawman?
So in order to show you
now I have my computer
here in front of me, usually
you would rather do it
on a piece of paper but
just for recording purpose,
this is a bit easier.
And you will always start
by creating a basic grid
on your paper, just to
resembling the slides.
And now of course, the idea
is that each of these squares
resembles an individual page
later in the presentation.
So what you will always start with
is to come up with the
action title of the slides.
The action titles are very
special types of titles.
If you have no idea
what action titles are,
these are key concepts
when creating PowerPoint presentations,
and I will insert a link somewhere above
where I explain exactly
what an action title is
and how you set it up.
If you don't know what
it is really check it out
because it's super important to create
consulting style presentations.
So once you do that
number writing it here,
and let's now for instance,
just talk about a company
that wants to improve costs
or anything like that.
Then the first slide
could for instance say,
company
is in market
with x percent growth.
So just in the beginning,
you maybe want to lay the
scene and just say okay,
actually the market
environment is doing quite well
and the market is growing.
And what do we usually do is just to do
a brief version of the action title,
it doesn't need to be the
perfect version already,
just a brief sketch of
what the action title
is supposed to be in the end.
And then what you also do is just do
a basic sketch of the type of chart,
the type of graph that you want.
So here for instance,
you could do a bar chart
maybe with a CAGR inserted
just to give you a gist
of what is going on.
Then the next one could maybe
be that you want to highlight
that the company actually is
under competitive pressure.
So market share of company is
decreasing due to competition.
And here for instance, you could
do some relative bar charts
where they are all 100% just
to show how the market share
of a company changed over time.
So this is now the market
share you might want to depict.
Then this is now going down.
Next, maybe we want to
show how the profitability
of the company will be
affected in the long term.
So for instance, you could
now do a waterfall chart
from 2020 to 2021,
say profitability will go down by 200,000.
And then maybe next to
propose a couple of measures.
So for instance, there could
be three areas now, right,
where you believe that the
company needs to improve on
in order to survive and to make a shift
in this new environment.
And the next maybe there
will be some backups
for these three parts one,
two, and three explaining
how exactly these measures
are supposed to look like.
And then you can here
insert a couple of notes
on what exactly is supposed
to be inserted here.
Next, maybe there's a
timeline for the project,
when will this be completed?
And then you write the project timeline
goes on to end of 2021.
This probably not the best action title,
but just something of this line,
then you maybe draft a Gantt chart,
if this is now, possibly to understand
how this might look like,
and so on, and so forth.
So I hope you get the
idea what I'm looking for.
This is then how you will
draft the whole presentation.
And then of course, this
is then a piece of paper
that you give on to your associate
or if you're the partner, maybe
you then share it with a team
or with a project lead,
asking them to create the
presentation like this,
but you can also use it
the other way around.
So if you are an associate
and you have an idea
of how to structure a document
that now you want to create,
now instead of really writing it all out,
instead of already
creating the whole document
and only then getting the feedback
that maybe your project lead
actually wants to do it
the whole other way around.
What I always found is
super great way to do,
is just briefly sketching
your presentation
in such a way, sketching it in this way,
where you have then the whole document,
the whole presentation on paper,
you then go to your project
lead with this piece of paper
and then you discuss the presentation,
the whole flow of the
pages, the whole storyline.
Just as you have it in your head
based on such a piece of paper.
And this will always lead to a very great
and constructive discussion
with your team lead.
And the best thing is
drafting something like this
will only take you a couple of minutes,
so you haven't really
invested a lot of work.
And if you find out that
your project lead
would like to do it completely different,
would like to tell the story
in a completely different way,
you haven't already wasted
the time creating slides
that in the end will not even be used.
And this is something that unfortunately,
happens quite a lot in consulting
but I trust many corporate jobs as well.
While editing this video, I
just wanna use this opportunity
to make you aware of my online course
on slide writing presentations.
I created an online
course that already has
over 10,000 students enrolled in it,
teaching you all the things
I learned at McKinsey
of how to create consulting
style slide presentations.
So if you think this is something
that might interest you,
check out the link in
the video description
with a link to that course.
Thank you guys but now let's
continue with the video.
I hope this was clear and you found
this little introduction
into drafting presentations
in the style of top management
consultancies helpful.
Of course as always, if
you have any questions,
let me know, write me a comment
below in the comment section
and I will do my very best
to answer every single one.
If you took any value at
all out of this video,
please hit the like button.
This really helps me with
the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to this channel,
if you want to see more videos like this.
If you want to see even
more content from me,
I also have an Instagram,
the handle is @FirmLearning
and I have an email mailing list
with regular content as well.
You can find a sign up
link to the mailing list
below in the video description.
Thanks for watching,
I really enjoyed this
very much appreciated
all of you took this time on the Saturday.
See you next week,
I release at least one video
every week on Saturday.
Until then, great weekend to all of you.